欢迎你学习白泽国际战运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们重点来讲解怎样去分析竞争对手
知己知彼先胜而后求战
通过分析竞争对手我们可以获取很多的信息
通过这些信息,通过这些数据来为我们运营店铺做决策
以及我们的方向的调整做决策
那么接下来我们重点来各个小板块的学习
我在这个板块主要是讲一些具体的思路
因为当你有了思路之后
你可以通过很多维度去找到对应的数据
然后再根据这些数据去判断
然后做出决策就可以了
因为我们之前讲了很多的内容
这个板块也会涉及到之前讲过的内容
所以这里就不会进行非常详细的讲解
第一个就是怎么样去找到我们同行的大量优秀的店铺
一定是品类加款式属性高度一致的店铺
也就是说你们做的品类是一致的
同时你们的产品的款式风格是差不多的
因为产品的款式风格差不多的时候就决定着你们国家市场是相似的
以及你们的买家群体是相似的
那么这样的店铺才具备参考性
才能够更加精准的进行数据对比
那么这里面会用到一个表格去统计同行的一个链接, 也就是优秀同行店铺的链接, 我们在日常中去收集一下, 那么坐在表格里面, 到时候我们想要去参考同行的时候, 直接打开链接就可以了
第一个步骤就是先找到同行店铺, 然后分析它, 得出结果, 通过这些结果, 我们去执行自己店铺的具体的一些计划, 就可以了
第一步就是我们用的工具就是插件
那么这里推荐的一个插件就是瞬息
这里面有非常多的板块可以应用
当然有可能有些板块是需要收费的
但是这个不是我的软件
所以说你可以根据你的需求购买或者是说采用免费的版本都可以
第二个就是我们可以通过榜单里面去找到收秀的店铺
榜单里面你看这里有个维度
这里有维度
那么我们先通过榜单进入去看产品, 产品了之后直接点击他们的店铺
点击店铺, 看了整体的交易额啊, 或者是整体的品类, 产品款式, 属性等等, 是不是跟你们店铺的高度一致
如果是高度一致的, 而且它的效果也做得很好的, 我们直接把它记录到表格
作为你的一个同行的竞争对手, 到下一次进行分析
第二个板块就是我们到中厂板块, 制造商板块, 去把前五的这些商家全部把他们的链接拿下来
那么拿下来之后呢,以后我们就去分析它就可以了
接着我们可以通过关键词去搜索
我们在国际站首页输入我们产品的核心关键词
然后找到自然排名很好且五星的店铺
我们就要把它这些店铺风格属性品类都跟你们店铺一致的时候
就把它放到这个表格里面, 作为以后参考, 你在这里搜集到的, 跟在这里搜集到的, 跟在这里搜集到的这些同行, 有可能会有一些重复的, 所以你在这里先复制链接, 到时候去从就可以了, 那么最后一个板块就是, 从搜索列表, 也就是PC首页搜索列表, 左侧找到平台年投入资金, 土豪的店铺, 也就是你看这些等级, 可能都投入在50万以上,
100万以上的店铺, 这些店铺通常来说, 他能投入这么多的资金, 有大部分是做的比较好的, 所以可以参考, 但是这些店铺也有可能做的不好的, 所以说你自己去筛选一下, 反正这些就是投入的金额很多, 所以说他在运营上面应该投入也不会太低, 一定要重点参考这些, 接下来我们继续去看, 怎么样去分析同行的优秀店铺, 刚才我们是找到店铺, 现在是分析店铺,
那么我们只要重点分析我们能改变的指标就可以了
很多人都去分析那些我们无法改变的指标那些是没有意义的
为什么我们店铺做没人就做的好
有些指标是你没办法改变的
那么我们就不用参考了
我们只去参考我们能够改变的
那么这个具体分析思路是怎么样的呢
我们先要明确分析的指标是哪些
然后通过对比分析得出一些规律得到总结
把这些结论应用到我们的店铺里面去
按照我们的计划跟方向去执行就可以了
第一个就是店铺的星级跟年线
这个年线我们是没办法改的
但是星级我们可以提升
第二个就是经营状况
你看这些就是经营状况
整体的经营状况
交易额多少
它的每六个月交易比数是多少
以及它的主营市场是什么
它在北美,澳大利亚, 南美
这些市场都值得我们去参考
如果我们做的市场跟它一模一样
那么是不是说明这个店铺跟我们相似度极大
那么是不是我们分析它就有非常大的意义,非常大的价值
我们就可以去参考它
它做了这么多交易,那我能不能做得到
它做了那么多交易额,比数, 交易比数, 这些我们能不能做得到
你要去盘点资源和分析
要做到哪个数据维度才能够跟它一样
第四个就是店铺赛道
虽然说我们都是同一个行业的是吧,但是有些店铺赛道是不一样的, 有的人专门做RTS, 有的人全部都是做定制, 有的人是做半托管的店铺
那你就要去看他哪类产品发的非常多, 哪类产品发的多就代表着他做哪一个赛道, 所以说你一定要去分析这些维度
你不要拿你的定制赛道跟RTS赛道比, 那是比了也没有用, 因为你只能是说参考的款式去做定制的款式
因为它这个流量本来就是不是一个层级的
RTS流量大多数情况都是比你的定制店铺的流量大的
所以说没办法完完全全准确的对比
第五个就是店铺的主打产品
你一定要去了解它店铺里面的主打产品是什么
比如说它在产品分组里面
首页产品分组里面会有一个优秀销售的产品
那么你就去看它的这些销售产品它都在卖什么产品为主
这些卖的产品一定是它重点推广的产品
同时你要去看一下它的橱窗产品
这些橱窗产品一定是它数据很好的产品
或者是说它最近在主要经营的产品
再加上它的主营认证产品
这些产品都是它重点在扶持, 重点花钱, 重点关注的产品
你就通过它的分组橱窗以及认证产品去看就可以了
那么你就知道它的整个店铺在主打什么品类, 以及什么风格, 这些产品有什么特征就可以了
通过判断它的这些产品,我们可以去及时的挖掘一些比较有潜力的产品去发到我们的店铺上面去
或者是说我们推广产品,选择迷茫的时候,可以直接参考它的这些款式
看看我们有没有能做的这些款式,我们也可以去测试一下这些产品去推广
第三个就是我们刚才说, 找到了同行周秀店铺链接, 去分析同行店铺, 现在是怎么样去找到同行高转化的产品
找这个产品来做什么呢?就是为了能够让我们选到更加好的产品跟款式去推广, 或者是去发产品
这个目的主要就是这个, 同时也可能就是为了去提升我们产品的一个转化率
为什么人家的高转化产品做得那么好?我们是不是去参考一下我们如何优化我们的产品?如何布局我们产品详细页, 起定量, NOQ, 价格, 还有, 邮会券, 如何去设置, 来提升我们整体的一个转化?
那么我们从哪些维度去找到这些高转化的产品呢?根据我这个路径, 第一个, 市场参谋, 看一下, 商机分析里面的产品榜单, 第二个维度就是买家参谋, 买家参谋里面有个买家行业偏好产品, 买家权利, 买家全
就按照我写的这个维度去判断就可以了
第三个就是榜单,刚才我们已经讲过了
这个榜单里面一二三三个维度里面去选品
接下来就是同行优秀店铺
我们刚才前面已经说的, 收集好了同行的店铺的间接了
我们打开他们的店铺, 去看一下他们店铺里面的这些产品的分类
一个个去看,找到跟我们相似的
第五个就是会采购, 因为能够报名这个活动的产品
活动的产品, 基本上都是数据比较好的产品, 而且是他们在主导的产品, 如果经验丰富的一些运营, 或者是说做的比较好的店铺, 他们去报名的这些活动的产品都是非常好的, 所以说我们在这个板块里面也可以参考选择产品, 这个板块对于我们的产品选择有非常高的价值参考, 因为这个报名活动只有三个产品, 而且是美洲报名, 而且他的条件也比较苛刻, 所以通过一, 二, 三,
455个维度, 我们就能够去选择合适我们的产品的款式风格, 然后去推广, 那么以上这些板块都可以作为一个参考的维度, 我们不要在意它是否绝对百分百的准确, 但是只要有参考, 它就有一定的价值, 不然我们就是方向目标都不明确, 那么我们做的更加的迷茫, 所以说有参考总好过, 没有的好,
在接下来的话, 我们怎么样去分析同行转化产品
第一个就是捉住同类产品, 一定是同类的
你比如说你做的AE品类, 你就去分析人家的B品类, 这没意义的
你做A类, 那么你也去分析同行的A品类就可以了
按照这种去分析
那么我们分析的重点指标, 第一个就是产品的款式跟烹格
第二个是价格区间, 起定量, 以及它的许蛮数, 主要消亡哪些国家
这些板块我们都是可以直接从插件里面或者是说在产品详情页里面获得这些资料
我们把高种化的产品的一个链接放在这里一看
这里这是第一个,第二个链接, 第三个链接, 按照这种方式去看
看一下它的标题,关键词, 这个都可以用插件获取, 这标题都可以看得到
那么这些可以作为我们选词的一个维度
那么这些就可以作为我们设置产品的一些属性, 价格, 区间, 启定量等等
这些询盘量就能够让我们知道我们大概需要补充多少询盘或者是获得多少询盘的时候
才能跟他有这么好的一个排名
或者是能够跟他抢到这个位置的排名
主要销售的国家的话一定要非常的注意
因为同样的产品如果他在这几个国家卖得非常好
如果我们推广的国家变成了非洲的一些国家
很有可能就是我们的产品卖的不好
因为他已经帮我们验证了
在这几个国家卖的非常好
我们直接优先这些国家去推广
或者是说先做这些国家去测试
那么我们就能够缩减我们的推广范围
我们在有限的预算下面
我们就不需要测在多国家了
那么这个就能够省下一些预算
给到这些核心的国家
首先的话我们这个是通过插件分析的
我们点击产品分析
想营业里面就可以看到
这个单品, 它交易比数, 总买家数, 总交易量是多少, 这些维度都可以看到, 这个插件就是瞬息, 用商品分析, 点击
接下来的话, 下面的这个板块, 刚刚出来的这个板块, 这是我们详情页自带的一些数据, 我们可以直接点进这个转化好的产品, 然后就看了详情页, 然后点击它的一个整体的一个数据, 这里, 点击数据, 更多数据,
点击它的数据之后就出现这些数据, 以及这些数据, 是不是就能根据这些时间的维度去看一下这些数据到底多少
我们是不是就有一定的参考价值, 就知道我们店铺里面的这类产品
我需要做到什么层级的数据才有这么好的一个排名, 或者是说交易, 按照这种思路去做就可以了
那么以上就是关于我们讲如何去进行分析竞品
第一个是找到同昂优秀店铺的链接, 第二个就是分析这些同昂的店铺, 第三个就是怎么样去找到高转化的产品链接, 第四个就是如何分析这些高转化的产品, 第五个就是我们通过这些维度分析了之后, 把我们所要做的事情列出来, 把我们的计划写出来, 然后再开始去执行就可以了,
那么我们的方向和以及具体要做的事情就非常的清晰了
那么我们来总结一下我们所学到的内容
第一个就是通过两个路径进行分析竞争对手
第一个是店铺维度,第二个是产品维度
通过店铺各项指标判断以及产品的各项指标判断
来获得有效的产品信息跟数据
然后通过这些数据为我们提供决策
做成我们的店铺运营的方向, 加运营的策略, 加具体要执行的内容
那么这个是不是我们的整体的一个运营的一个目标计划表吗
第二个步骤就是我们先找到同行游戏店铺分析各项数据
第二个就是找到平台的热销产品, 分析产品, 对比自己店铺的产品, 找到差异和总结出规律, 然后开始调整
第三个就是如果遇到问题不懂的马上列出来当天解决
那么这个就是关于分析竞争对手的一些整体的思路跟一些比较简单的方法
通过这些方法我们还可以在实践的过程中自己去思考衍生出更多相关的一些方法
这节课我们就讲到这里下节课我们再见